every employee can have the perspective
of a business owner where you are a
business of one and you have one
customer which is the business that you
work with and they are your customer and
so you provide services to the business
in exchange for money the same value
equation of speed ease risk and
exceeding expectations are still used
just like making a product when
delivering a service to anyone and so if
you want to be a great employee can you
do the thing that you're doing faster
than other people or faster than they
expect can you make the risk that you
[__] it up lower than they would
otherwise expect can you make it easier
for everyone else who works around you
and your boss to get work from you or
work with you and then finally is the
final product of the thing match or
exceed what they asked you to do if you
do those things you will always get the
promotions and you will always move up
in the company because you will give
them proof that you are better than
everyone else based on value